[موسيقى]
نعم
ما نتحدث عنه اليوم هو أنه
تم الآن إجراء أول اختبار للركاب لأول وسيلة
نقل جماعي جديدة
لدينا منذ 100
عام ونحن نتحدث الآن عن
شيء  سرعة مذهلة تصل إلى 600
ميل في الساعة ،
وهي سعة عالية مطلوبة
ومرنة بالطريقة التي نريد أن نعيش بها
حياتنا التي يمكن أن تنقل
الأشخاص والبضائع وفوق كل
ذلك
فهي صديقة للبيئة
[موسيقى]
سأعطيك مثالاً  كولومبوس أوهايو
إلى بيتسبرغ بنسلفانيا
إذا كنت قد أخذت أي شخص في
كولومبوس وقلت كم تبعد
بيتسبرغ ، سيقول الجميع ثلاث
ساعات
مع هايبرلوب أقل من 25
دقيقة [موسيقى]
أعتقد أن أحد الأشياء التي يجب أن
تتعرف عليها بشأن السلامة
هو أن هناك  ليست طرقًا مختصرة ، وفي
بعض الأحيان يعتقد الناس
أن ذلك لعنة للشركات
التي تبادر بسرعة إلى
ريادة الأعمال المبتكرة بالطريقة التي
تفعل بها ذلك ،
فقد تبنت هذه الشركة virgin hyperloop أسلوبًا
حقيقيًا  الثقافة الأولى لما نقوم به
[الموسيقى]
لديّ جار يسمى
هايبرلوب هايبرلوب هايبرلوب نعم هل
هو مثل نفق جيتسون إنه
شيء من هذا القبيل
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن ما نبحث عنه الآن  هي
شهادة ستتم
في
عام 2025 أو
2026 وأعتقد أنك ستكون قادرًا على رؤية
مشاريع هايبرلوب قبل نهاية
العقد ،
إنه ليس بعيدًا نحن في الوقت الحالي
حيث نحن الآن جاهزون لذلك  اجعل هذا يحدث